en 2023 la SNCF est le Comité Régional
du Tourisme Paris Île-de-France se sont
alliés pour favoriser le tourisme en
train le contrat a été signé en avril à
Maisons-Laffitte c'est dans ce cadre que
s'inscrit l'offre de tourisme durable
c'est pas loin en train j'ai décidé de
tester en montant à bord de la ligne L
au départ de Saint-Nom-la-Bretèche on va
aller prendre le ticket ouvert à la fin
des années
1880 la gare de Saint-Nom la Bretèche
située à l'Étang-la-Ville accueille le
T13 et le Transilien l qui dessert Paris
Saint-Lazare seulement 29 km sépare les
deux gares mais avant ça on va
télécharger l'application c'est pas loin
en train gratuite proposer par la SNCF
l'application vous donne des
informations sur les lieux qui entourent
vos gares là par exemple on se trouve à
Saint-Nom la Bretèche et l'application
m'indique qu'à une minute de marche
seulement de la gare vous pouvez
randonnée entre les châtaigniers à
quelques pas de la gare se trouve la
forêt domaniale de Marly-le-Roi ancien
domaine de chasse des rois de France
puis des présidents de la République
aujourd'hui c'est 2000 hectares de
verdure font le plaisir des randonneurs
chaîne châtaigniers clairières ou encore
étant regorge dans cette forêt
[Musique]
après cette première découverte du
patrimoine yvelinois direction
Marly-le-Roi
[Musique]
à seulement 13 minutes de la gare à pied
se trouve le château de Monte-Cristo on
va aller à sa découverte pour se rendre
au château près de 2 km traversant
Marly-le-Roi et Le Port-Marly
[Musique]
on est bien arrivé au château de
Monte-Cristo à Port-Marly de la gare on
a mis une vingtaine de minutes un peu
plus que le temps indiqué sur
l'application mais le chemin est plutôt
agréable et le château vaut le détour
c'est en 1847 qu'Alexandre Dumas se fait
construire ce château inspiré du décor
de ces romans après le succès des trois
mousquetaires et du Comte de
Monte-Cristo il cherche à s'établir dans
un lieu paisible château Renaissance
parc romantique à l'anglaise cascade ce
lieu devient son havre de paix
[Musique]
on poursuit notre périple on vient de
s'arrêter à la gare de Louveciennes à
proximité de laquelle se trouve le
château de Madame Dubarry mais avant ça
nous allons nous balader sur le chemin
des impressionnistes
de mon planning
je pars vers le bon feeling pour vous
rendre au château de Madame Dubarry je
vous propose une balade rafraîchissante
sur le chemin de la machine qui a
inspiré de nombreux peintres en 1873
Alfred Sisley pense ce paysage
incontournable de l'option
[Musique]
c'est ici que la famille royale a
construit le château de Madame Dubarry
en 1769 Louis XV offre cette demeure à
sa favorite elle y fera ensuite
construire le pavillon de la musique
et c'est ici que s'achève notre visite
nous sommes sur le chemin de la machine
d'un côté le chemin des impressionnistes
de l'autre le château de Madame dubary
alors si vous aussi vous souhaitez
découvrir les Yvelines en train
rendez-vous sur l'application c'est pas
loin